Andy Larsen jazz beat writer for Salt
Lake Tribune host of NBA weekly show on
our affiliate kalle ESPN 700 good
morning Andy how are you I'm doing okay
I'm how surprised are you or you know
the basketball community that this fan
who had the confrontation with Russell
Westbrook has been banned for life from
a game I don't think anyone that
surprised I think quite frankly once
this became as as large of a deal as it
was I think the Jazz had to move this
and almost no matter what actually
happens but that being said the Jazz did
the investigation they have video
evidence they've got eyewitness accounts
of the fan said what Russell Wesley said
he said and as a result you know there's
just no place for him in evidence Mario
Moreno was a jazz and so they've banned
him twice not only from jazz games but
any concerts any other sporting events
that might happen in the arena at all do
we know the full story because we only
heard Russell Westbrook audio and we
didn't hear the fans yeah Westbrook said
and the Jazz investigation confirmed
that the fans said get on your knees
like you're used to was the specific
contracted at Westbrook that caused him
so much anger and honestly it's it's not
the first time that Westbrook had either
you know semi racial or kind of frosting
the wine comment
directed at in his way so you kind of
understand why why he reacted it in the
way he did I I don't know that it was
there's the right thing to do regardless
of that but but so I mean it this point
the investigation is pretty clear that
Russell Westbrook is telling telling the
truth on on this yeah and I know that
Russ had to be fined and or suspended he
got fined 25k you can't threaten
certainly somebody's wife but you can't
threaten a fan either way he was wrong I
know that you know it was difficult for
him to try to hold back I'm guessing but
also this fan now says he's suing
Russell Westbrook what he's he's suing
the bait on the basis of
that is a great question and that
lawsuit hasn't been filed you know I I'm
not sure if that would be you know kind
of the questions that his employer has
gotten from the local news media
including myself you know I don't know
if that would be the fact that he has
had to kind of go into hiding he he told
reporters that he's gotten death threats
about this issue you know I don't know
what it is because again that lawsuit
hasn't been filed all I know is that I
was reporting that yes he did said he's
going to be suing russell westbrook i
you know i from my knowledge of the
legal system and based on this
investigation
I can't foresee him winning that lawsuit
but hey that's what that's what people
do right I looked at his social media
Andy I mean once this happened and
Seaton pulled up his social media and I
went boy this guy does not have any
ground to stand on here as it was ugly
on his social media yeah you're totally
right and he definitely seems like a
piece of work even even in kind of the
the interview that they they did right
after with ksl did with same title as
his name and you know it seemed like a
guy who was used to telling that version
of the life that you know hey hey here's
what I said but here's how you
misunderstood it and that's how he kind
of got away with that kind of behavior
in the past is the story over I I don't
think so you know for a couple of
reasons one you know we'll tack the
lawsuit moving forward but to more
importantly I don't know if you've seen
this video that Eric Woodard of the
different is posted yesterday but
there's this video of fans calling
Russell Westbrook boy during last year's
playoffs when the choose teams match
them in the first round and so that you
know again it's pretty clear racial
connotations that and clearly again
crosses the line so I think there's
going to be kind of an ongoing
conversation with jazz fans with Utah
fans about what okay and what's not okay
and what you know free agents coming to
Utah I don't know that there's going to
be a lot of those but how does that
affect kind of the NBA players view of
Utah which was
you know truthfully safety to begin with
Andy good stuff thanks for joining us we
appreciate your time I think that Andy
Larson jazz beat writer for The Salt
Lake Tribune for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]